До кінця року Україна має шанс отримати Томос
про автокефалію православної церкви в країні -
це документ, який надається новій автокефальній церкві і яким
визнається право церкви на незалежне управління.
Утім, як відомо, в Україні є церкви, храми та іншібудівлі
Української православної церквиМосковського патріархату.
Що буде з цим майном?
Юридичної особи "Українська православна церква Московського патріархату"
в Україніне існує. Тобто немає єдиної структури,
за якою були б закріплені усі церкви та інші будівлі
Московського патріархату.Власником кожного об'єкта церковної нерухомості,
як правило, є іншіюридичніособи.
Наприклад, власником Почаївської лаври є релігійна організація
"Почаївська Свято-Успенська Лавра" -юридична особа,
керівником якої є митрополит Володимир.
Тобто об'єкти лаври - уприватнійвласності.
"Приватизація" Почаївської лаври розпочалася за прем'єрства Віктора Януковича.
У липні 2003 року він підписав розпорядження Кабміну
про виключення зі складу Кременецько-Почаївського державного заповідника
споруд Почаївської Свято-Успенської лаври.
ІшлосяпроУспенськийсобор, Троїцький собор,
монастирськікелії, архієрейськийбудинок, дзвіниці та надбрамнийкорпус.
Цей найдавніший монастир України фактично розділений на дві частини:
Нижню і Верхню Лаври.У липні2013 року Кабінет міністрів України
за прем'єрства Миколи Азарова передав у безоплатне користування
Свято-Успенській Києво-Печерській Лаврі, тобто Московському патріархату,
79 будівель і споруд, серед яких лабіринти Ближніх і Дальніх печер.
Тож нині фактично вся Нижня Лавра підпорядковуєтьсяУПЦ МП.
Так звана ж Верхня Лавра до цього часузалишається у державній власності
в управлінні міністерства культури України.
За різними оцінками, це лише 15-20% території.
Надання Томосуі створення єдиної
помісної православної церкви в Україні не є підставою для переділу майна.
Прийняття будь-якого рішення у релігійній сфері не може вплинути на правочин.
Якщо уряд просто скасує старе розпорядження,
релігійна організація може звернутись до суду
і визнати рішення незаконним, кажуть юристи.
В інфопросторі вже поширюються повідомлення,
що будівлі УПЦ МП начебто забиратимуть силою і передаватимуть
єдиній Українській православній церкві.
Предстоятель УПЦ Київського патріархату Філарет
спростовує це і запевняє, що після Томосу не буде насильства.
Заклики захоплювати Лавру, за словами Філарета, є провокацією.
Законним Філарет вважає інший варіант переділу майна.
За українськими законами, всі храми і майно належать громадам:
чи на правах власності, чи на правах користування, чи на правах оренди.
І якщо громада вирішила вийти з одного патріархату та увійти до іншого,
то майно вона зберігає за собою. На думку експертів,
вийти з МП парафіям буде вигідно, бо їм не потрібно буде вже відраховувати гроші у Москву,
а єпископи отримають широку автономію.